my parents made me what I am I am the
protector of the deep hey everybody it's
Charlie this is gonna be my non-spoilery
review of Aquaman also try to rank my
favorite DC EU films at the end of the
video too because now they're been six
so it's pretty easy to do a top 5 list I
know there a lot of questions about what
this movie means for the future of the
DC EU people are wondering about reboot
and all that stuff so I'll try to
address that as I talk about what the
movie did how it did it and how it
compares to the other DC movies so far
we're doing a new round of that imax
ticket giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite aquaman moment on the video so
we'll start with the story then I'll
talk about the characters how they
change the Aquaman character from
previous incarnations during the Zack
Snyder Justice League Batman vs Superman
because we have seen versions of Aquaman
before in this universe but the Aquaman
movie treats him in a very different way
early on there were a lot of comparisons
to the plot of the Black Panther movie
where a king needs to take his throne
but a brother or like a family member
tries to take it from him so they have
to do battle there's this journey of
self-discovery and self-actualization as
they become the true version of the
comic-book character within their own
respective universe DC Universe or the
MCU but really that's where the
comparison ends like the Aquaman movie
is so different from Black Panther so it
doesn't feel like it at all even though
in a very basic surface level if you try
to tell someone the plot in less than 5
seconds they might sound similar like it
is very very different it looks very
different the Aquaman movie felt a lot
bigger like it escalates to global scale
much more quickly than the Black Panther
movie did and nowhere is that more
evident than the big huge action scenes
so one of the high points of the film
was the way they treated the big action
scenes because as you see from the
trailers that could have been a couple
potential problems like it does feel
kind of formulaic the way that he has to
battle his brother ocean master for the
throne of Atlantis and if you've ever
watched the animated movie or you read
the comics obviously it was inspired a
lot by that story but James Wan and the
fight choreographers did a really good
job trying to turn their big big battles
into much more interesting affairs then
say something like you would see at the
end of the Wonder Woman movie which is
probably one of the weakest parts of
that film most people talking about the
movie or folk
singing on the tone in how it's so
different from previous DC movies and
nowhere is that more evident than in
Jason Momoa character himself they had
started to get there a little bit with
his character during Justice League he
does have a couple funny moments but
mostly he's this background linebacker
that just walks around looking badass
and a really cool piece of armor with
his Quinn dent but you don't really get
a sense for his personality to there on
the back of Batman ship and they have
that funny confessional scene where
Aquaman sort of accidentally but totally
on purpose
puts the lasso of truth underneath him
so he completely spills his guts to them
there was a big question about what
Jason Momoa is gonna feel like trying to
carry a movie by himself I will say
thankfully he's a great version of
Aquaman and he can totally do this
I think there are a couple things they
need to tweak for potential sequels but
if you've been watching the Chinese box
office like they released it in China a
little while ago and it's been doing
gangbusters so it sounds like what's
gonna happen is is the international box
office all by itself will guarantee a
sequel they've already started talking
about that but we can get into that when
I talk about spoilers and Easter eggs
the movie itself does a great job of
world-building because it's all fresh
territory like you've never really been
to Atlantis but for a couple quick
scenes during Justice League so
obviously there are a lot of huge visual
changes in the way they portray that
James Wan himself said that when he
started working on this a couple years
ago while they were still ramping up on
production for Justice League he said
that Warner Brothers just let him do
whatever he wanted they're like this is
great he obviously visited the set a lot
when they were doing Batman vs Superman
in Justice League so he had a chance to
talk with Zack Snyder and the other
filmmakers that were involved with those
movies but when it actually came time to
writing and designing what everything
was gonna look and feel like he just
decided to do his own thing one of the
benefits being that there aren't really
any times during the Aquaman movie when
it steps on the toes of stuff that the
other movies have done there are bits of
crossover but without getting into
spoilers I'll say it's mostly Easter Egg
level so like it doesn't necessarily
tell you what's going to be happening at
a lot of these other DC movies because
they have a lot of different filmmakers
that are coming in working on them but
the film is part of the DC Universe
there are lots of points of connection
lots of references characters talking
about things that happen during the
other movies so this takes place after
Justice League if that
and clear it's about a year after the
events of Justice League so awhile has
gone by but obviously I know a lot of
you want to know about the villains
Black Manta is a huge comic book
character big fan favorite I feel like
even though ocean master did a good job
I'll talk about him in a second Black
Manta because he's potential sequel
material was one of the best things
about the film even though he wasn't
around as much as you would expect him
to be but one of the minor complaints
that I had about the movie was some of
the ways that they used pop songs during
certain points the actual original score
was pretty good like Aquaman has a great
theme song black mantas theme song was
one of my favorites so I'm really
looking forward to what they do with him
in the future of the universe
obviously he's fair game for any Aquaman
sequels but the actor teased that he
could pop up in other DC movies too so
it'll just depend on what those other DC
filmmakers want to do if they want to
borrow the character but I'm only
expecting him right now in whatever the
Aquaman sequel winds up being there's a
lot of talk about Jason Momoa chemistry
with Amber Heard I feel like she
actually did a pretty good job with Mira
there were a couple awkward moments with
the two of them on-screen together if
you've watched any of the junket
interviews that they've done they've
been posting a lot of them they get a
little awkward at times there were
moments in the movie that were just like
that where some of the jokes feel like
they don't quite land between the two of
them and they get a little too broad but
a lot of that you can fix with a little
extra work on the script like one of the
really big things that James Wan had to
deal with is that somebody else actually
cast his main leads which usually most
directors don't have to deal with like a
director has a very specific vision for
his movie the way it looks the way it
feels what the story is one of the
biggest parts of that is him finding the
actors that he feels like most embody
what he wants that vision to look like
and when you have main leads that
somebody else cast like Zack Snyder
you're trying to meld their vision with
your vision because Jason Momoa is like
the ultimate vision of what Zack Snyder
thought that Aquaman was not necessarily
other filmmakers it also kind of
happened with spider-man like Tom
Holland I think has done a great job
with spider-man but the Russos cast him
then when they get to spider-man
homecoming the director of that movie
John Watson fit Tom Holland into his
vision for spider-man homecoming instead
of starting from scratch but it went
great for spider-man in the MCU so I
also feel like it worked
for Jason Momoa inside the DC Universe
so James Wan did make appropriate use of
Jason Momoa in in terms of performance
and charisma the way he carries himself
he is definitely playing Jason Momoa on
screen like yes it's like the Jason
Momoa version of Aquaman but if you've
ever watched Jason Momoa in real life
like he does a lot of funny Instagram
and social media posts it feels a lot
like Jason Momoa just walking around
doing all the things that Aquaman would
be doing during this movie so when he
reacts the types of jokes that he tells
his personality you're mostly thinking
about Jason Momoa on-screen instead of
thinking about Aquaman so I think you
know they're probably some really
hardcore Aquaman comic book fans out
there that might feel like that's a
little bit weird but I think for most
people that would be fine and for most
of the other cast like the other
character actors like Willem Dafoe
that's playing volcko most of them slip
into those characters so you're not
thinking as much about Willem Dafoe
watching volcko and you're not thinking
as much about Amber Heard when you're
watching mera I haven't talked a whole
lot about ocean master but Patrick
Wilson I think did a pretty good job
with the material that they gave him
even though he's been in the DC Universe
before he was in Zack Snyder's Watchmen
I wouldn't say that it quite reaches the
Shakespear black panther levels of kill
monger but they did a good job with his
motivation and he does feel like a real
character like he's not a mustache
twirling villain and they do give him
places to go in potential future sequels
so if you're big Aquaman comic book fan
you will chuckle a little bit with a way
they referenced their comic book
personas because technically he has not
become ocean master when the movie
begins so even though very few people
that read comics refer to his character
is armed he sort of becomes that
character in the way that the Aquaman
character becomes the comic book Aquaman
character yes there is a big origin
story they try to tell it in a
roundabout way obviously they're trying
to do more non-traditional origin
stories with superheroes movies now just
because we've gotten so many Nicole
Kidman is a big part of that she is a
badass and the way that I never thought
that she would be like you see her do a
lot of drama on screen like she's been
in a lot of HBO series recently she's an
amazing actress but it is kind of fun
watching her do crazy stunts on-screen
so for the most part though you will
have a lot of fun seeing the way they
treat the lore and looking for all the
Easter eggs and it does feel like a
really fun re watchable movie that is a
really good
job of broadening the DC universe in a
direction that you've never seen before
mostly down into the ocean but
surprisingly it does get to a relatively
cosmic level so I am hoping for a future
potential Wonder Woman Aquaman crossover
in the future because she does get into
a lot of the bigger cosmic God level
stuff as well but a lot of that will
have to wait till we get to Easter egg
videos there are a couple of spoilery
things that I do really want to talk
about that we're really exciting during
the film but keep your eyes peeled for a
couple surprise cameos that are a couple
of voiceover cameos you may have heard
about in the news that you have to keep
your ears tuned for but they're really
cool so overall really fun film I mean
fans will be arguing about where this
sits in the top five DC movies so far
everybody has their favorites mostly
because of the characters they like in
the tone that they like but overall this
film really kind of sits in like a tide
top three status with Man of Steel and
Wonder Woman so I feel like for slightly
different reasons all these films are
the best of the DC Universe so far then
number four Justice League just because
it was a bit of a mess Batman V Superman
then obviously my least favorite film is
Suicide Squad but there's only been six
films so within a year or two we'll have
a lot more to compare this to
especially with Shazam that's coming up
pretty soon then Wonder Woman 1984 there
will be more Shazam stuff dropping in
January sometime I don't know what the
exact date is but they'll be dropping
new footage for that because the movie
isn't that far away so leave all your
questions in the comments below I'll try
to address that when I get to Easter egg
videos and once you have a chance to see
the movie just let me know what you
think of it in the comments below
but click here for all my flash arrow
Elseworlds crossover videos they just
drop some crazy big Easter eggs and
click here to rewatch my new spider-man
far from home trailer breakdown thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]